Hey, this is Jud from Jenson. And today
we're going to look at and take a bit of
a dive into the agent exchange layer.
So, the agent exchange layer is a
decentralized peer-to-peer networking
layer built by Jenson that lets tools,
agents,
machine learning workloads, inference
run on nodes that can discover each
other and communicate in this completely
encrypted environment. So, today we're
going to go through AXL, what it is,
some things that you can build with it,
and we'll run through a demo at the end.
And let's get started. So, what is the
agent exchange layer? It's a
peer-to-peer mesh network. It's a single
go binary that handles all the
networking. So, uh message routing, all
types of uh encrypted messages of of any
kind as long as it's bytes, and NAT
traversal. These nodes that are
connected to this network, uh they join
a bootstrap network, and then if one of
these nodes were to expose a public key,
um
other nodes can connect to that node,
deliver payloads, send and receive,
post, use different tools like MCP and
agent-to-agent. Um these apps that are
running on these nodes only talk to
localhost. So, they send HTTP requests
uh to localhost entirely. The The
default port for that is 9002, but you
can of course change this. And you can
use any language that you want. So, any
language you can make an HTTP request
will work. So, like JavaScript, Go,
Python, etc. Um it's entirely
application agnostic. So, you can send
pretty much anything as long as it's in
bytes.
And again, the way that these nodes find
each other, once they're connected to a
bootstrap node, is they have essentially
a phone number. So, each node has a
private key and a public key. And if you
expose a public key, you can send that
to somebody, you can post it somewhere,
and people will be able to connect to
your node and see what applications you
have that are deployed on your node. So,
at no point does any of this message
routing, any of this connection go
through any kind of central server. It's
purely, well, purely peer-to-peer. It is
truly peer-to-peer.
There's no port forwarding, there's no
cloud accounts, there's no DNS, there's
no root or kernel requirements. Uh it
runs completely in user space. Nodes,
once they're spun up, are again sending
HTTP requests. The port selected at your
localhost, so again, by default 9002. Um
and anytime that nodes communicate with
each other with a public key, if you
decide to share it, they are paying each
other directly through a mesh network,
but there's no central server. And you
can also create your own bootstrap nodes
as well. So, you don't even have to use
public ones.
So, your application interacts with a
node through three very simple HTTP
endpoints.
The first of these is called post/send,
and this is what lets you send data to
another peer using their public key,
which we mentioned earlier. The second
is get/receive, and this is what you use
to pull incoming messages. And each time
one message is received, the previous
one is dequeued. The third of these is
get/topology. This gives you your public
key, which will print to your terminal,
and it'll also let you see who else is
connected to whatever bootstrap node you
are also connected to.
That's it. That's the whole API for
basic use. It's send data, receive data,
and figure out who you are and who's
around, pretty much. So, as far as
encryption is concerned, when your node
is connected to the mesh network, it
means that you're also connected to a
bootstrap node. And when you are sending
messages from one node to another,
sending data from one node to another,
you're essentially your message content
might be passed through other nodes, but
it's still completely encrypted because
none of those nodes are able to see what
is being sent. They're able to see that
there's a handoff happening somewhere,
and maybe the the return and sender
address, essentially. But there's no way
that they can tell what the contents of
that message are.
There's two layers of security or
encryption at work here. The first one
is TLS service by hop. So, from each
time you hop from one, or when the
message hops from one node to another,
it's encrypted. And then there's also an
end-to-end payload encryption as well.
And that's what's really nice about
using something like AXL because you
don't have to configure any transport
layer security at all of yourself. It's
already built in. So, now let's talk a
bit about building using AXL. So, the
starting pattern for pretty much
everything is the the send and receive
pattern. So, there's two applications on
two different nodes, and one of them has
to be a sender and the other a receiver.
One node is going to be using the
post/send method
um with the destination's peer key, so
it knows where it's going, and then the
payload as the body. The other app is
going to be pulling get/receive, popping
each of those messages off of that queue
of receiving messages,
um and provide the sender's key as well.
So, both the sender and the receiving
nodes both know who is sending what and
who's receiving what. Because you have
to surface that public key, not the
private key, but that public node key,
which again is like that cell phone
number that we've discussed earlier. And
everything is going through this mesh
network of nodes. Agents can use this.
You can create peer-to-peer chat rooms.
You can create distributed machine
learning, decentralized machine learning
inference pipelines. You can have agents
communicating with each other, doing
research on local devices, and then
taking that information and creating
these little context packets for use
for, let's say, trading on something
like Delphi, um if you have the Delphi
SDK and the Delphi skills installed.
Um there's a lot you can do with AXL.
And then when you need a structured
response,
uh AXL also supports MCP and A2A. MCP,
or model context protocol, allows you to
expose named services running on your
node, and then allow other nodes, if
they have the service name and your
public key, to call those and receive a
structured JSON RPC response. And then
we have A2A as well. So, A2A is Google's
agent protocol. It allows skills to be
posted as services in a way on your
node, and allow other agents to find and
access those skills. By the way, uh both
of these, A2A and MCP, are in the AXL
repo. So, you can look at those, and
there's also some documented examples.
But for getting just getting started and
building something on those nodes, the
send and receive methods are pretty much
going to be the backbone of whatever you
build. All right. So, now that we know a
bit more about AXL, uh let's run through
the very short checklist to clone the
repo, get it running, spin up a node,
and get building. You're going to want
to clone the repo, uh CD into it, and
then use the build command, generate
your identity, which is going to
generate your private key. Never share
this, please. Do not share this. And
then you're going to configure the node
and generate um your public key, and
connect to a bootstrap node, and then
you're going to launch and verify
everything. Um all these instructions
and a lot more detail can be found in
the documentation on
docs.jenson.ai/docs/agent-exchange-layer.
Um there's also a get started page,
troubleshooting. We'll get more into
some of those other resources later, but
you can find everything right there as
well.
So, what are some of the things that you
can build with AXL? Well, for starters,
you could build something that revolves
around agent collaboration. So, you can
imagine two agents working on a research
problem. One of them is finding
information using web tools, aggregating
context. The other one is synthesizing
the findings, the context, into
something that's actionable. Completely
coordinating with no central
coordinator. Each running its own node,
so there's no server deciding which
agent talks to which agent at all. They
simply find each other by their public
keys and go.
You could also build a service registry,
like a tool marketplace, or pub/sub and
gossip, which is an example that does
ship with the repo, where tools are
published as services, and then other
agents can use MCP to find and then
utilize those tools.
There's also the opportunity for private
data exchange, to where you have it,
financial information, um model outputs,
uh medical data, all types of sensitive
data from one peer to another,
essentially in plain sight. Because
again, other nodes can see that there's
transmissions being made, but there's
two layers of encryption. There's the
hop-by-hop TLS, and then there's the
end-to-end encryption as well. And so,
you can send them whatever you want, and
nobody would know what you're sending.
You could do something with distributed
inference, where you take a model, split
it up across different nodes in the same
mesh network, and exchange tensors
directly, which you could then extend
into something like pipeline
parallelism, which essentially you take
that model and that inference workload,
you split one task on one task on one
task from different nodes, and each one
of those nodes does its part and passes
the activation on to the next one.
Um so, there's a lot that you can do
here. And then there's, of course,
anything peer-to-peer. So, multiplayer,
voting, um live editing, messaging,
anything at all that requires two
machines talking to each other that you
don't want to be centralized on somebody
else's hardware. AXL handles the
transport layer between those machines.
Two machines, three machines, four
machines, 100 machines.
Build whatever you want. And just a
reminder that if you want some
inspiration, the AXL repo also comes
packaged with um a good few examples
that are also documented. So, converge
cast, gossip sub, tensor exchange, and
of course the A2A client. So, you can
just take one of those, fork it as a
starting point, and see where it gets
you. And it doesn't have to be anything
necessarily that's AI related. If AXL
fits a use case that you have in mind,
go for it.
All right. So, now we know a bit about
AXL. We know what we can do with it, how
it works, how to get started, some of
the things that you can build with it.
Let's show what that looks like. So,
this is a really simple peer-to-peer
messaging app, a group chat that I built
using AXL. It's a fairly straightforward
application that uses some of the
requests that we've been talking about,
the post and the receive. It also
incorporates agents. So, I have an Open
Claw agent set up on one device running
in one terminal. So, I have the Gateway
off token there. And I've got four total
terminals. I've got two sets of two.
Two of these are sitting within
Crostini, which we'll see in a second,
and then two of these are in a dedicated
terminal instance, just so I can flip
back and forth pretty easily. So, and
I've configured them both to both be
listening to the same TCP, the same
port, so that I can simulate a second
device also pointing at its own
localhost, but knowing my public, my
first node's public key and being able
to to essentially join that chat room.
So, let's go ahead and get started. I'm
going to open up the service here, which
is the AXL group chat.
Give myself a name, and then name my
Open Claw agent instance, Mr. Guy.
And let's go ahead and change the theme
here a little bit, just to make it
really clear who is who. So, I'm going
to type a message, and now let's head
over here and get started.
So, because I'm running two nodes, and
I'm trying to simulate a second device
connecting, a second node connecting to
the service I have here. I've got one
Open Claw instance, so I'm not going to
trip things up by
bringing in an agent with me to both of
these instances, but that's of this demo
app here.
This was designed so that multiple
people could call and use one API key's
worth of Open Claw agent. So, one person
brings an agent through with their Open
Claw Gateway authorization token, their
key, and then multiple people can chat
with it, they can call it, they can use
it, and the Open Claw agent itself is
actually being passed. It's all the
messages in the chat are being fanned
out, and then appended to a context blob
that's sent along with each query to the
agent. So, the agent can participate,
can see, can see the surroundings, can
see all the messages that are being
sent, and multiple people can
essentially share for the duration of
one conversation an agent. So, I'm going
to type in a name, which is guest, but
we're not going to hit that second
that second name selection. So, I'm
going to say hello, and I'm going to go
over here and see that guest has said
hello. So, now this is two nodes
on the same connected to the same
bootstrap peer that are messaging each
other. And then the
Mr. Guy, hey.
What is the temperature
in Barbados?
So, I'm going to post that message, and
I've configured this in such a way where
I don't want the agent to be constantly
responding to everything. So, I just
gave it a at, you know, at name here, so
that it can be called at any point.
Well, it looks like Mr. Guy doesn't have
any live weather data, so I will say,
What is 1 + 1?
And what is blue? And
switch over here to the other instance
here.
Blue and yellow create what color?
Send that message, hop over back over
here, and then do Mr. Guy,
can you answer those two questions? And
so now what I'm showing here is that
there are multiple users in this chat
room that are able to both use the agent
by calling it specifically. And it's not
going to ignore the messages of the
other. So, one node connects to the
other node's service, but the Open AI
instance or the Open Claw instance is on
one of those machines being run through
that flag, and other people are able to
essentially use that. So, what's
happening here? One of the nodes is
doing the post send HTTP request from
one node to the other. The other one is
receiving it with the other node's key,
and then the other one is doing the
receive in a loop. As you can see, we
can send messages back back and forth.
It's completely bidirectional, and the
node is handling everything. The message
routing, the delivery, the encryption,
and the chat app is really just HTTP
calls to localhost.
All the hard stuff is in the node. It's
it's the functionality, it's the
infrastructure components that make up
AXL.
We could build this in an hour and go a
lot further than this.
Everything that you need to get started,
to get up and running with AXL, is in
the AXL repo. You can clone into
everything, you can read some of the
included documentation, get started. But
again, all the resources can be found in
the repo.
And if you hit a wall, we have
troubleshooting documentation and a
Discord community that you can join at
any point to ask questions. Of course,
you have a wealth of documentation over
on our docs platform. That's a wrap. So,
I am super excited to see what you build
with this. So, get out there and build
something cool.
Thanks for watching.